foreign
hi everyone welcome to this artificial
intelligence 2022 full course video by
simply loan artificial intelligence
applications are being widely used in
various fields to solve business
problems in this video you will learn
the important skills that will help you
understand Ai and its implementation
better
a highly proficient trainers will take
you through this course
so let's look at the agenda for today's
topic
we will start by learning the basics of
AI from a short animated video then you
will learn the top 10 AI Technologies
and companies for 2022.
next you will understand machine
learning in detail and explore some of
the top machine learning algorithms that
are used to build intelligent machines
so here you will look at linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k-means clustering k n PCA and
other techniques such as regularization
reinforcement learning and Q learning
moving forward you will understand the
working of artificial neural networks
and deep learning algorithms such as
convolutional neural network recurrent
neural network Keras image
classification and sequential model so
let's get started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the House a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
Incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but AI may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact AI is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an AI do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the AI robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other Rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short AI provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide Solutions
well now that we know what AI is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
in AIS classified into
weak AI also called narrow AI focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak AI
you might say Alexa is definitely not a
weak AI since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask Alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito and
runs a program and is trained to Alexa
cannot respond to a question it isn't
trained to answer for instance try
asking Alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
Alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of AI strong AI
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now Ultron
from Avengers is an ideal example of a
strong AI
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions this
makes the ai's response unpredictable
You Must Be Wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning we
saw what AI is machine learning is a
technique to achieve Ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning machine learning provides a
machine with the capability to learn
from data and experience through
algorithms deep learning does this
learning through ways inspired by the
human brain this means through deep
learning data and patterns can be better
perceived Ray Kurzweil a well-known
futurist predicts that by the year 2045
we would have robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of Singularity
well that's not all in fact Elon Musk
predicts that the human mind and body
will be enhanced by AI implants which
would make us partly cyborgs so here's a
question for you which of the below AI
projects don't exist yet a an AI robot
with citizenship B a robot with a
muscular skeletal system C AI that can
read its owner's emotions D AI that
develops emotions over time give it a
thought and leave your answers in the
comments section below since the human
brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains for now ai is built
to work with humans and make our tasks
easier
however with the maturation of
Technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of AI holds for us well
that is artificial intelligence for you
in short do not forget to leave your
answer to the quiz in the comments
section below also like share and
subscribe to our Channel if you enjoyed
this video stay tuned and keep learning
now let's look at the different types of
artificial intelligence
so AI can be classified based on
capabilities and functionalities
under capabilities there are three types
of artificial intelligence
they are narrow AI General Ai and super
AI
under functionalities we have four types
of artificial intelligence reactive
machine limited memory theory of mind
and self-awareness let's look at them
one by one
first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on capabilities
so what is narrow AI
narrow AI also known as vki focuses on
one narrow task and cannot perform
Beyond its limitations
it aims at a single subset of cognitive
abilities and advances in that Spectrum
applications of narrow AI are becoming
increasingly common in our day-to-day
lives as machine learning and deep
learning methods continue to evolve
Apple Siri is a simple example of a
narrow AI that operates with a limited
predefined range of functions
Siri often has challenges with tasks
outside its range of abilities IBM
Watson supercomputer is another example
of narrow AI which applies cognitive
Computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your questions
IBM Watson once outperformed human
contestant Ken Jenkins to become the
champion on the popular game show
Jeopardy other examples of narrow AI
include Google Translate image
recognition software recommendation
systems spam filtering and Google's page
ranking algorithm
next we have General artificial
intelligence or general AI General AI
also known as strong AI has the ability
to understand and learn any intellectual
task that a human can
General artificial intelligence has
received a one billion dollar investment
from Microsoft through open AI it allows
a machine to apply Knowledge and Skills
in different contexts AI researchers and
scientists have not achieved strong AI
so far to succeed they would need to
find a way to make machines conscious
programming a full set of cognitive
abilities
Fujitsu built the K computer which is
one of the fastest computers in the
world
it is one of the most notable attempts
at achieving strong AI
it took 40 minutes to simulate a single
second of neural activity so it is
difficult to determine whether or not
strong AI will be achieved in the near
future
tan HE2 is a supercomputer created by
China's national university of Defense
technology
it currently holds the record for CPS at
33.86 petaflops
although it sounds exciting the human
brain is estimated to be capable of One
exaph log
now CPS means characters per second that
A system can process
third in the list of AI that is based on
capabilities we have super AI super AI
exceeds human intelligence and can't
perform any tasks better than a human
the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees AI evolved to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characteristics of super AI include the
ability to think solve puzzles make
judgments and decisions on its own
now if you have enjoyed watching this
video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section A team
of experts will help you address your
questions
moving ahead now we will see the
different types of artificial
intelligence based on functionalities
in this category first we have reactive
machine
a reactive machine is the basic form of
AI that does not store memories or use
past experiences to determine future
actions
it works only with present data they
simply perceive the world and react to
it reactive machines are given certain
tasks and don't have capabilities Beyond
those duties
IBM's deep blue which defeated just
Grandmaster Gary Castro is a reactive
machine that sees the pieces on a chess
board and reacts to them
it cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice
deep blue can identify the pieces on a
chessboard and know how each moves
it can make predictions about what moves
might be next for it and its opponent
it can choose the most optimal moves
from among the possibilities deep blue
ignores everything before the present
moment
all it does is look at the pieces on the
chessboard as it stands right now and
choose from possible next moves
up next we have limited memory
limited memory AI learns from past data
to make decisions
the memory of such systems is
short-lived
while they can use this data for a
specific period of time they cannot add
it to a library of their experiences
this kind of technology is used for
self-driving vehicles
they observe how other vehicles are
moving around them in the present and as
time passes
that ongoing collected data gets added
to the static data within the AI machine
such as lean markers and traffic lights
they are included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle
Mitsubishi Electric is a company that
has been figuring out how to improve
such technology for applications like
self-driving cars
then we have theory of mind
theory of Mind represents a very
advanced class of technology and exists
as a concept this kind of AI requires a
thorough understanding that the people
and the things within an environment can
alter feelings and behaviors
it should be able to understand people's
emotions sentiment and thoughts
even though a lot of improvements are
there in this field this kind of AI is
not complete yet
one real world example of theory of Mind
AI is Kismet a robot had made in the
late 90s by a Massachusetts Institute of
Technology researcher Kismet can mimic
human emotions and recognize them both
abilities are key advancements in theory
of Mind AI but Kismet can't follow gazes
or convey attention to humans
Sofia from Hanson robotics is another
example where the theory of Mind AI was
implemented
cameras within Sofia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see
she can follow faces sustain eye contact
and recognize individuals
is able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem
finally we have self-awareness
self-awareness AI only exists
hypothetically
such systems understand that internal
traits States and conditions and
perceive human emotions
these machines will be smarter than the
human mind
this type of AI will not only be able to
understand and evoke emotions in those
it interacts with but also have emotions
needs and beliefs of its own
while we are probably far away from
creating machines that are self-aware we
should focus our efforts towards
understanding memory learning and the
ability to base decisions on past
experiences I am Keith and today we
shall be talking about the top 10
artificial intelligence Technologies
before getting into the video he has a
gentle reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon so that
you wouldn't miss any update from us so
without further Ado let's quickly jump
into the topic in the list we have
natural language generation smart
devices virtual agents speech
recognition augmented reality machine
learning robotic process automation
decision management
deep learning and finally image
recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information
efficiently and transparently is very
much crucial in communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence to convey the message clearly
humans often find it tricky and when it
comes to machines it's trickier
natural language generation is a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structured data into a
native language the machines are
programmed in such a way that the
algorithms convert the data into a
desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are at Evo
automated insights SAS Kindred semantics
digital reasoning narrative science
Etc
on the list next we have Smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using Once
Upon A Time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects meet
intelligent with Advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users and other smart devices
some of the smart devices are smart
watches smart glasses smartphones smart
speakers
Etc virtual agents they are computer
generated intelligence that provides
online customer assistance they can
effectively communicate with humans in
most of the web and mobile applications
we see chat Bots as customer service
agents who interact with us answering
our queries
in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology which aims
to create an effective but digital
impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment place an order and
can even Avail product information some
of the best examples of virtual agents
are Google assistant and Amazon Alexa
and the companies that provide virtual
agents are Microsoft Google Amazon and
assist AI
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence which is used to convert
human speech into a comprehensive and
useful format for Computer Applications
to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it's presently used in interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are Nuance
Communications open text n ice and
wherein systems
augmented reality yet another trendy
technology in the field of artificial
intelligence augmented reality is an
enhanced version of the real physical
world that is achieved using sound
digital visual elements and other
sensitive stimuli delivered via
technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment it
Alters the perception of the real world
environment augmented reality is making
its way into several retail stores that
make makeup selection and Furnishing
much more fun and interactive if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
machine learning machine learning is an
application and an important branch of
artificial intelligence which refers to
machines being able to learn by
themselves without being explicitly
programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms apis big data and
applications and training tools
Enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization and prediction
how to sample vendors are Amazon
fractal analytics Google Microsoft
Etc robotic process automation
configuring a report to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses grips and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous
Fields like Warfare mining Etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
Talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation are Pega systems
automation anywhere blue prism
Etc next on the list we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
Decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and Performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
Insurance sector e-commerce and many
more
the companies that provide this service
are Informatica Advanced systems
Concepts Pica systems Mana
Etc deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchy level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several Industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
Instinct fluid AI math Works saffron
technology
Etc
at last we have image recognition image
recognition is the process of detecting
an object or feature in a digital image
or video it can be used to analyze
clients and their opinions verify users
based on their faces detect license
plates and diagnose diseases
present the image recognition is
comparable to human visual perception
many social media platforms like
Facebook use this technology to enhance
innate search and Aid visually impaired
users clarify Googles and senstein
provide this technology
decades ago the term artificial
intelligence was just another
Frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door right from
its Genesis artificial intelligence was
programmed to probe into human life and
eliminate the fortifications of the
impossibilities in many areas like
healthcare Transportation communication
and much more there are hundreds and
thousands of organizations Tech
communities and Engineers worldwide
working Round the Clock to make Miracles
a reality and today we are going to
discuss the top 10 amongst those who are
contributing a significant part so here
we are the top 10 artificial
intelligence companies to watch in 2022
at number 10 we have this AI this AI is
a revolutionary approach to dramatically
improvise the way Healthcare is
delivered with AI focuses on
implementing artificial intelligence to
diagnose and detect abnormalities in the
human body via CT CTA MRI X-ray EKG
ultrasound Etc
this AI coordinates both the patient and
Healthcare professionals at the same
time the patient reports are shared Via
Mobile to all the concerned Medical
Teams results are astonishing with with
AI there is a significant Improvement in
productivity and reduction of time
required for patient treatment and
discharge this AI was founded in 2016
and established in November 2021. the
company runs with 223 employees and the
headquarters is in San Francisco
with AI mainly focuses on improving and
filling all the gaps between patients
and Healthcare professionals with AI
offers handsome salaries to its
employees in India the salaries range
from 4 lakhs to 18 lakhs per annum and
in America the wages range from one ten
thousand dollars to two ten thousand
dollars per annum so at number nine we
have Farm boys ten years ago an
automated wheat killing Robo was science
fiction
now its rise of practical weed killing
Robos with millimeter Precision thanks
to farmwise the first product of the
californian-based company was an
automated robo-weeder based on AI
computer vision and also robotics the
robot would eliminate weeds from the
vegetable fields farmwise intends to
build Innovative systems and efficient
procedures that help farmers streamline
farming with efficiency farmwise was
established in the year 2020 the company
functions with 50 employees on board and
actively looking for expansion
the company follows the procedure of
paying farming equipment employees and
contract Personnel hourly
farmwise makes an annual turnover of 8.5
million US Dollars on average an AIML
engineer at farmwise earns anywhere
around 113
000 per annum
up next we have amp robotics at number
eight we have amp robotics While others
are busy trying to revolutionize mankind
with AI amp robotics came up with an
Innovative idea that happens to be a
kind gesture of gratitude towards nature
amp AI designed an artificial
intelligence Robo that recycles E-Waste
plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more
the robo precisely identifies paper
Plastics and metals by learning and
recognizing them via color size shape
and a few more factors the
colorado-based company is currently
operational with 137 employees in total
and looking forward to expand the ideal
globally AP robotics aims to
re-imagining recycling and to create a
world without waste through artificial
intelligence amp robotics pays handsome
salaries to their employees with an
average salary of an employee amp
robotics varies between ninety six
thousand dollars to one Thirty one
thousand dollars per annum coming up
next is a giant at number seven we have
automation anywhere automation anywhere
is a global robotics Automation and
software company founded in the year
2003. the company's headquarters is
located in San Jose California
the global RPA leader offers Cloud
native web-based intelligent automation
solutions to the world's leading Cloud
companies
automation anywhere's automation 360
offers a variety of intelligent tools
and self-learning systems to automate
every redundant task
automation anywhere is focusing on
transforming the companies to be RPA
oriented and the current covet
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more a recent survey
States the RPA adoption rates will
increase by 57 in just one more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than 2 200 plus
employees on board
the company pays decent salaries as well
at number six we have Microsoft AI
Microsoft integrated AI into cloud
computing Microsoft's AI platform
provides robust solutions to Cloud
related problems Microsoft's AI division
is headquartered in Redmond Washington
with around 5000 employees specifically
in the AI Division and aims to train and
certify 15 000 employees by 2022
Microsoft AI is a robust framework
designed for developing AI Solutions
using machine learning data science
Robotics iot and more AI enables
Services accelerate productivity to a
greater level
Microsoft Azure uses AI to get best of
breed infrastructure with Enterprise
create security availability compliance
and manageability Microsoft also pays
Hanson salaries to their employees the
average salary of an employee at the
Microsoft AI division earns up to 160
000 per annum
at number five we have data Robo data
Robo has its headquarters in Boston it
is one of the AI Cloud leaders providing
a unified platform to its Cloud users to
accelerate the delivery of AI to the
cloud
data Robo aims to understand and
Leverage The inherent capabilities of
the platform data Robo has the caliper
to help business analysts in building
Predictive Analytics with no knowledge
of machine learning it uses automated ml
to build and deploy accurate predictive
models in a short span of time
the global Cloud leader currently
operates with more than a thousand
employees worldwide
data Robo compensates its employees with
handsome salaries an average employee a
data Robo earns up to 160 000 per year
and up to three lakh 400 000 rupees in
India
at number 4 we have Amazon the Alexa
Maker Amazon is one of the tech Giants
interested in adopting AI into its
various divisions
Amazon calls it's AI Services Amazon Lex
Amazon poly Amazon recognition and
Amazon machine learning
these services are accessible through a
software API call or console the Amazon
AI suit of services can have text or
voice conversations with an end user
using a conversational chat Ops
interface
the seattle-based tech giant is
currently using AI for its Smart Home
Solutions
AI companies like Alexa and its business
intelligence needs Amazon is also
conducting trials on drone delivery to
save time and efforts to deliver goods
and services to remote locations with
ease
Amazon AI aims to provide biometric
payments to its customers at cash free
stores
the approach is still in Trials Amazon
calls it just walk out technology
Amazon has enormous teams and pays
decent salaries to its employees for
example an employee at Amazon can earn
up to 20 lakh rupees per annum in India
and about a hundred thousand dollars per
annum in United States of America
at number three we have data bricks data
breaks is one of the best data driven
companies data bricks lake houses
combine data warehouses reliability
performance and governance with the
openness and flexibility of data Lakes
data brick is headquartered in San
Francisco California and has 15 office
locations across 11 countries
the company announces plans on
delivering keynote on data and machine
learning product Innovations and the
rise of the lake house architecture
advancements
data bricks currently operates with 2000
plus employees globally
the organization compensates its
employees with handsome salaries an
average employee at data breaks makes
about 154 000 US Dollars and around 2.1
lakh rupees per annum in India
next we have meta at number two we have
Meta Meta formerly known as Facebook is
innovating an advanced way of social
interaction
meta has integrated artificial
intelligence and it's being called The
Meta AI meta AI has its headquarters in
Toronto Canada
meta AI has redesigned a new material
and touch sensor with potential to boost
the development of metaverse
a team of researchers at the metaverse
have worked jointly with Scientists at
Carnegie Mellon University to build
reskin a plastic three millimeter thick
membrane with Magnetic particles capable
of measuring touch and sensation
a thrilling experiment meta has under
its sleeve I would say meta currently
operates remotely with about 350
employees on board critics also state
that meta pays a vast salary to its AI
experts with an average salary of 1 lakh
750 000 paid to the employees at meta AI
at number one we have Google AI Google
AI is the division of Google dedicated
to artificial intelligence
announced it at Google IO 2017 Google AI
has its headquarters in California
Google AI is demonstrating its Quantum
Computing Supremacy with its new and
Powerful cinemore processor Google's AI
is one of the most widespread
Technologies it's almost everywhere from
your language translations to helping
people with speech impairments to have a
successful conversation social media
interactions shopping lists and
assisting users with GPS sending alerts
to its users about natural calamities
and saving them Google AI has announced
that its research team is designing Next
Generation AI chips for a smart future
in addition a new AI Model A loves
artificial intelligence to perform chip
design that more efficiently solves
unique aspects of any problem with an
artificial neural network Google AI
currently works with our four divisions
with massive teams we have come to an
end of the this session on the top 10 AI
companies to watch out for in 2022.
hello and welcome
[Music]
simply learn my name is Richard
kirschner I'm with the simply learned
team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you today well
we'll start off with a brief explanation
of why machine learning and what is
machine learning and then we'll get into
a few of the types of machine learning
machine learning algorithms linear
regression decision trees support Vector
machine and finally we'll do a use case
where we're going to classify whether
recipe is of a cupcake or a muffin using
the svm or the support Vector machine
sounds like a delicious way to explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machines can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with Google's
waymo and then uberhead their program
which unfortunately crashed they know
that this is huge this is going to be
the huge industry to change our whole
transportation Asian infrastructure
machine learning is now usually ticked
over 50 eye diseases do you know how
amazing that is to have a computer that
double checks for the doctor for things
they might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that within
some areas where maybe not for eyes but
for other diseases where they're using
the camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go in and see
the doctor and because the machine can
now unlock your phone with your face I
mean that's just cool having it being
able to identify your face or your voice
and be able to turn stuff on and off for
you depending on where you're at and
what you need talking about an ultimate
automation or world we live in and as we
dig in deeper we have a nice example of
Facebook as you can see here they have
the Facebook post with Halloween comment
yes if you want it order here nobody
likes spam post on Facebook that annoy
them into interacting with likes shares
comments and other actions I remember
the original ones were all if you don't
click on here you will have bad luck or
some kind of Fear Factor well this is a
huge thing in a social media when people
are getting spammed and so this tactic
known as engagement bait takes advantage
of Facebook's news feed algorithm by
choosing engagement in order to get the
greater reach to eliminate engagement
bait the company reviewed and
categorized hundreds of thousands of
posts to train a machine learning model
that detects different types of
Engagement bait so in this case we have
we're using Facebook but this is of
course across all the different social
media they have different tools for
building and the Facebook scroll GIF
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there and notices that there's
a certain setup with Facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of General titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that Takes Over part of the Facebook
setup that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what Facebook did to eliminate this
as they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
Facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport in a lot of countries you have
like hundreds of people trying to sell
you time share come join us sign up for
this eliminates that annoyingness so now
you can just enjoy your Facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures mine is family certainly
people like their cat pictures too
another good example is Google's Deep
Mind project alphago a computer program
that plays a board game go has defeated
the world's number one go player and I
hope I say his name right key G the
ultimate go challenge game of three of
three was on May 27 2017 so it's just
last year that this happened and what
makes this so important is that you know
go is just is a game so it's not like
you're driving a car or something in our
real world but they are using games to
learn how to get the machine learning
program to learn they wanted to learn
how to learn and that is a huge step a
lot of this is still in its infant stage
as far as development as we saw what
happened with the as I referred to
earlier the Uber cars they lost their
whole division because they jumped ahead
too fast so still at infant stage but
boy is this like the beginning of just
an amazing world that is automated in
ways we can't even imagine what
tomorrow's going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning so let's see if we can give a
little bit more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is a science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed and we see
here we have a nice little diagram where
we have our ordinary system and your
computer nowadays you can even run a lot
of stuff on a cell phone because cell
phones advance so much and then with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it now takes the data and it
learns from what happened before and
then it predicts what's going to come
next and then really the biggest part
right now in machine learning that's
going on is it improves on that how do
we find a new solution so we go from
descriptive where it's learning about
stuff and understanding how it fits
together to predicting what it's going
to do to post scripting coming up with a
new solution and when we're working on
machine learning there's a number of
different diagrams that people have
posted for what steps to go through a
lot of it might be very domain specific
so if you're working on Photo
identification versus language versus
medical or physics some of these are
switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to The Domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to Define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to click the data that matches
you spend a lot of time in data science
collecting data in The Next Step
preparing the data you got to make sure
that your data is clean going in there's
the old saying bad data in bad answer
out or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we've cleaned all this
stuff coming in then you're going to
select the algorithm which algorithm are
you going to use you're going to train
that algorithm in this case I think
we're going to be working with svm the
support Vector machine then you have to
test the model does this model work is
this a valid model for what we're doing
and then once you've tested it you want
to run your prediction you want to run
your prediction or your choice or
whatever output it's going to come up
with and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing then you
want to go ahead and deploy the model
remember I said domain specific this is
very General as far as the scope of
doing something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey I'm not
really getting the answers I need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model it's a very
good model to start with and we do have
some basic divisions of what machine
learning does that's important to know
for instance do you want to predict a
category well if you're categorizing
thing that's classification for instance
whether the stock price will increase or
decrease so in other words I'm looking
for a yes no answer is it going up or is
it going down and in that case we'd
actually say is it going up true if it's
not going up it's false meaning it's
going down this way it's a yes no zero
one do you want to predict a quantity
that's regression so remember we just
did classification now we're looking at
regression these are the two major
divisions and what data's doing for
instance predicting the age of a person
based height weight health and other
factors So based on these different
factors you might guess how old a person
is and then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm I'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days another question that
comes up which is on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure in unexplored data
and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar Behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographic and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to Market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to Market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any Arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and Investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before you even start
looking at whether they're valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to Cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick DeTour for quiz time
oh my favorite so we're gonna have a
couple questions here under a quiz time
and we'll be posting the answers in
these part two of this tutorial so let's
go ahead and take a look at these quiz
times questions and hopefully you'll get
them all right it'll get you thinking
about how to process data and what's
going on can you tell what's happening
in the following cases of course you're
sitting there with your cup of coffee
and you have your checkbox and your pen
trying to figure out what's your next
step in your data science analysis so
the first one is grouping documents into
different categories based on the topic
and content of each document very big
these days you know you have legal
documents you have maybe it's a Sports
Group documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world B
identifying handwritten digits in images
correctly so we want to know whether
they're writing an A or capital A B C
what are they writing out in their hand
digit their handwriting C behavior of a
website indicating that the site is not
working as designed D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience with HR hiring uh
set up there so stay tuned for part two
we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
Simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it back to our regular content
and these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jumble of data with
circles triangles and squares and then
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict what whether
someone's going to default that alone
because it's talking about Banks earlier
supervised learning on stock market
whether you're going to make money or
not that's always important and if you
are looking to make a fortune in the
stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates in ways you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is or what a triangle is
and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
we'll group it by the number of corners
and it notices that a number of them all
have three corners a number of them all
have four corners and a number of them
all have no corners and it's able to
filter those through and group them
together we talked about that earlier
with looking at a group of people who
are out shopping we want to group them
together to find out what they have in
common and of course once you understand
what people have in common maybe you
have one of them who's a customer at
your store or you have five of them are
customer your store and they have a lot
in common with five others who are not
customers at your store how do you
Market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demographs of who's going to shop there
and you'd like them to shop at your
store and not the one next door of
course this is a simplified version you
can see very easily the difference
between a triangle and a circle which
might not be so easy in marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning or an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result we have
here where the in this case a baby it's
actually great that they used an infant
for this slide because the reinforcement
learning is very much in its infant
stages but it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now or in the future it's
going to be coming up over the next few
years is reinforcement learning and how
to make that work for us and you can see
here where we have our action I mean the
action in this one it goes into the fire
hopefully the baby didn't think it was
just a little candle not a giant fire
pit like it looks like here when the
baby comes out and the new state is the
baby is sad and crying because he got
burned on the fire and then maybe they
take another action the baby's called
the agent because it's the one taking
the actions and in this case they didn't
go into the fire they went a different
direction and now the baby's happy and
laughing and playing reinforcement
learning is very easy to understand
because that's how as humans that's one
of the ways we learn we learn whether it
is you know you bring yourself on the
stove don't do that anymore don't touch
the stove in the big picture being able
to have machine learning program or an
AI be able to do this is huge because
now we're starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervise versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on we have in
supervised learning we have labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said yes
that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predicted outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in in the picture so you can see
how they go back and forth and you can
start connecting all these different
tools together to make a bigger picture
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms let's have a look at
a few of them hopefully this gives you a
little flavor of what's out there and
these are some of the most important
ones that are currently being used we'll
take a look at linear regression
decision tree and the support Vector
machine let's start with a closer look
at linear regression linear regression
is perhaps one of the most well-known
and well understood algorithms in
statistics and machine learning linear
regression is a linear model for example
a model that assumes a linear
relationship between the input variables
X and the single output variable Y and
you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals MX plus C
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed X our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times X plus
C or distance equals m times p speed
plus C where m is the coefficient and C
is the y-intercept and we're going to
look at two different variations of this
first we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness speed equals 10 meters
per second and so over a certain amount
of time his distance equals 36
kilometers we have a second bicyclist
who's going twice the speed or 20 meters
per second and you can guess if he's
going twice the speed and time is a
constant then he's going to go twice the
distance and that's easy to compute 36
times 2 you get 72 kilometers and so if
you had the question of how fast would
somebody is going three times that speed
or 30 meters per second is you can
easily compute the distance in our head
we can do that without needing a
computer but we want to do this for more
complicated data so it's kind of nice to
compare the two but let's just take a
look at that and what that looks like in
a graph so in a linear regression model
we have our distance to the speed and we
have our m equals the ve slope of the
line and we'll notice that the line has
a plus slope and as speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals MX plus C distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing us
three times 10 meters per second that
this is roughly 102 kilometers distance
to this third bicep this has traveled
one of the key definitions on here is
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive as distance
increase so to speed increase let's take
a look at our second example where we
put distance is a constant so we have
speed equals 10 meters per second we
have a certain distance to go and it
takes them 100 seconds to travel that
distance and we have our second
bicyclist who's still doing 20 meters
per second since he's going twice the
speed we can guess he'll cover the
distance in about half the time 50
seconds and of course you could probably
get on the third one a hundred divided
by 30 since he's going three times the
speed you can easily guess that this is
33.333 seconds time we put that into a
linear regression model or a graph if
the distance is soon to be constant
let's see the relationship between speed
and time and as time goes up the amount
of speed to go that same distance goes
down so now your m equals a minus v e
slope of the line as the speed increases
time decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this and even a significant
amount of data let's see what the
mathematical implementation of linear
regression and we'll take this data so
suppose we have this data set where we
have x y x equals one two three four
five standard series and the Y value is
three two two four three when we take
that and we go ahead and plot these
points on a graph half you can see
there's kind of a nice scattering and
you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it but we're going
to calculate that exact line for linear
regression and the first thing we do is
we come up here we have the mean of x i
and remember mean is basically the
average so we added five plus four plus
three plus two plus one and divide by 5.
that simply comes out as three and then
we'll do the same for y we'll go ahead
and add up all those numbers and divide
by 5 and we end up with the mean value
of y of I equals 2.8 where the x i
references is an average or means value
and the Y I also equals a means value of
y and when we plot that you'll see that
we can put in the y equals 2.8 and the x
equals 3 in there on our graph and we
kind of gave it a little different color
so you could sort it out with the dashed
lines on it and it's important to note
that when we do the linear regression
the linear regression model should go
through that dot now let's find our
regression equation to find the best fit
line remember go ahead and take our y
equals MX plus C so we're looking for M
and C so to find this equation for our
data we need to find our slope of M and
our coefficient of c and we have y
equals MX plus C where m equals the sum
of x minus X average times y minus y
average or y means in X means over the
sum of x minus X means squared that's
how we get the slope of the value of the
line and we can easily do that by
creating some columns here we have X Y
computers are really good about
iterating through data and so we can
easily compute this and fill in a graph
of data and in our graph you can easily
see that if we have our x value of 1 and
if you remember the x i or the means
value is 3 1 minus three equals a
negative two and two minus 3 equals a
negative one so on and so forth and we
can easily fill in the column of x minus
x i y minus y i and then from those we
can compute x minus x i squared and x
minus x i times y minus y i and you can
guess it that the next step is to go
ahead and sum the different columns for
the answers we need so we get a total of
10 for our x minus x i squared and a
total of 2 for x minus x i times y minus
y i and we plug those in we get 2 10
which equals 0.2 so now we know the
slope of our line equals 0.2 so we can
calculate the value of c that'd be the
next step is we need to know where it
crosses the y-axis and if you remember I
mentioned earlier that the linear
regression line has to pass through the
means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just back up there to
that graph and you can see right here
there's our means value which is three x
equals three and Y equals 2.8 and since
we know that value we can simply plug
that into our formula y equals 0.2 X
plus C so we plug that in we get 2.8
equals 0.2 times 3 plus C and you can
just solve for C so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line Y equals 0.2 times X
Plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of Y using x equals one two
three four five and plot the points
remember the one two three four five was
our original X values so now we're going
to see what y thinks they are not what
they actually are and we plug those in
we get y of designated with Y of P you
can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on and so one
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think is going to be when we
plug those numbers in and when we plot
the predicted values along with the
axial values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things that's
very important with linear regression in
any of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted X and Y and
Y predict and we'd run a little line so
you can sort of see what the arrow looks
like there between the different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error Etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
squared distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
Dimensions y equals MX plus C but you
can take that out to x z i j Q all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems than the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spreadsheet you can
see we have the Outlook whether it's a
rainy overcast Sunny temperature hot
mild cool humidity windy and did I like
to play golf that day yes or no so we're
taking a census and certainly I wouldn't
want a computer telling me when I should
go play golf or not but you could
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next whatever you know
next meal out in this case is tomorrow a
good day for playing golf based on the
weather coming in and so we come up and
let's determine if you should play golf
when the day is sunny and windy so we
found out the forecast tomorrow is going
to be sunny and windy and suppose we
draw our tree like this we're going to
have our humidity and then we have our
normal which is if it's if you have a
normal humidity you're going to go play
golf and if the humidity is really high
then we look at the Outlook and if the
Outlook is sunny overcast or rainy it's
going to change what you choose to do so
if you know that it's a very high
humidity and it's sunny you're probably
not going to play golf because you're
going to be out there miserable fighting
off the mosquitoes that are out joining
you to play golf with you maybe if it's
rainy you can get more in Navigator
resource cases
foreign
good personification we want to go ahead
and divide our books up well organizing
objects into groups based on similarity
is clustering and in this case as we're
looking at the